moving overseas deadly demonstrations
against Iran's ruling regime are in
their fourth week now it's all unrest it
began after 22 year old Masha amini died
in the custody of Iran's morality police
that's what they have over there
Security Forces continue to respond with
Force trying to crush the protests that
have become increasingly anti-government
in general Roxanna siberi shows us how
some people are risking their own lives
to help injured demonstrators and we do
warn you as we so often do that some of
the video in this story is disturbing
death to the dictator rang out across
Iran for a fourth weekend in a row
while in this video shared with CBS News
schoolgirls chanted woman life freedom
activists say Security Forces appear to
be getting more brutal like killing this
driver for simply honking in support of
the protesters
and even firing pellets at school kits
these girls escaped but many other
protesters have not most of the injured
fear going to the hospital
this doctor in Iran told CBS news on
condition of anonymity because there
some have been detained so he treats
them at their homes despite threats to
himself
they'll show me a picture of their
injury and they'll say what do I do Dr
Kevon mirhadi says many injured Iranians
have even reached out to him in New York
on Instagram appealing for medical
advice or referrals to doctors he trusts
in Iran it goes from
bullets real bullets
to pellets uh bird shots so you're
basically walking injured protesters
through what they need to do to treat
themselves I have step-by-step
um
kind of instructions on what to do with
burns with bullets I put post on gunshot
wounds to the chest one post on the
abdomen today despite the risks
resistance is spreading some shopkeepers
are going on strike hackers interrupted
state-run TV with the message join us
and stand up and more women are
symbolically strolling the streets
without the required headscarves
for CBS mornings Roxanna
[Applause]